bonjour monsieur le Premier ministre je
m'appelle Gabriel Paul je suis membre de
la Première nation des pecagamulz de ma
ch merci d'accorder cette entrevue à
Espace autochtone d'abord quand vous
parlez de vérité quand les questions de
vérité réconciliation qu'entendez-vous
par là c'est de reconnaître que le
Canada d'aujourd'hui
a été façonné affectée par les succès du
passé mais aussi les erreurs du passé de
reconnaître que les peuples autochtones
ont été soumis à une un attentat
d'assimilation et de d'effacer leur
identité leur culture leur langue qui se
passait pas seulement dans le passé mais
qui est aussi des articulations très
très courantes aujourd'hui dans l'avenir
c'est sans reconnaître la vérité de
notre société de notre pays donc
si on parle de vérité c'est aussi la
reconnaissance que le système de justice
ne fonctionne pas pour les autochtones
particulièrement pour les femmes
puisqu'elles représentent près de la
moitié de la population carcérale au
pays effectivement il y a des
quand on pense aux écoles résidentielles
au pensionnats qui enseignait aux
enfants autochtones qu'ils n'avaient
aucune valeur que leur langue n'avait
aucune valeur leur culture leur identité
ne comptait pour rien faut se souvenir
que dans toutes les autres écoles
partout au pays où les nonattons étaient
on enseignait à peu près la même chose
que les cultures autochtones que la
langue autochtone l'identité autochtone
va les moins que la culture canadienne
en général et ça malheureusement cette
réflexion est non seulement ancrée dans
la population en général mais aussi dans
nos institutions que ce soit notre
système de justice notre système de
santé nos systèmes d'éducation il y a
une discrimination un racisme systémique
ancré parce que cette mentalité qu'on
condense dans les pensions autochtones
se glissaient aussi dans notre culture
en général alors si on veut réellement
reconnaître la vérité et défaire et
avancer sur la voie de la réconciliation
faut comprendre que nos institutions ont
besoin de changer parce que nos
institutions ont été façonnés par et
basé dans une mentalité qui n'est qui
n'est forcément fausse donc vous parlez
de changement des
qu'est-ce que votre gouvernement compte
faire pour mettre ça en pratique une
branche un grand exemple c'est la
protection des enfants depuis plusieurs
années on a mis de l'avant de la
législation un projet de loi qu'on a
façonné avec qu'on écrit avec les
communautés des leaders autochtones pour
s'assurer que des jeunes qui sont à
risque dans des communautaires soit pas
enlever de leur communauté de leur
culture de leur langue mais évidemment
ça c'est quelque chose que le
gouvernement fédéral peut faire donc on
prend que des PJ a les services de
protection des enfants des provinces ont
un rôle important à jouer là-dedans et
nous on veut que ces jeunes dans des
communautés qui sont à risque puissent
rester dans leur communauté soit occupé
par soit pris en charge par la
communauté elle-même pour ça ça prend
des investissements ça prend des
meilleures structures c'est des
changements de système et pour ça c'est
pas juste le gouvernement fédéral
gouvernants provincial doit avoir son
rôle à jouer les municipalités et
surtout des systèmes de gouvernance
autochtones elles-mêmes
justement de faire sur un pied d'égalité
donc avec le taux détermination et la
reconnaissance des droits territoriaux
des Premières nations je me demande
pourquoi sa chance là il y a encore des
contestations en cours quotawa men
contre la reconnaissance des droits
territoriaux en même temps que oui des
concepts contestation dans certains
endroits il y a d'autres mesures où
qu'on est en train de trouver des
règlements on est en train de de
reconnaître et de compenser les gens par
exemple la nation c'est que en Alberta
on vient de signer un dédommagement de
1.3 milliards de dollars parce que on
leur a enlevé des terres il y a 100 ans
de façon complètement illégitime donc il
y a bien des processus qui sont en cours
et nous on est en cours de ce passé on
préfère ne pas faire ça du vent les
tribunaux si on peut éviter les
tribunaux c'est mieux mais des fois oui
il y a des différents régler dans les
tribunaux mais de façon idéale ça règles
en conversation en négociation en
reconnaissant notre part de la faute
mais aussi en investissant pour bâtir un
avenir meilleur et pas juste rester pris
dans le passé
ce province sont prêts à reconnaître des
gouvernements des potentiels
gouvernements autochtones avec des
assistantes territoriales on a déjà fait
plusieurs reconnaissances il y a bien
des
communautaires d'automne qui sont
auto-gouvernants il y en a d'autres qui
s'en viennent je pense que c'est un
processus vers lequel il faut qu'on
aille mais c'est pas la grande priorité
de toutes les communautés il y a des
communautés qui disent non non on veut
établir notre système de santé avant de
avant d'établir notre système de
gouvernance ou on veut transformer notre
système d'éducation les communautés
elles-mêmes ont le droit de choisir leur
priorités nous notre rôle en tant que
gouvernement c'est d'être là pour les
accompagner avec les ressources
nécessaires à leur rythme et selon leur
priorité ça va être trop longtemps que
les priorités sont avancées d'Ottawa et
on dit OK ou des gouvernements pour dire
voici ce dont vous avez besoin mais
si c'est pas la priorité des
communautaires autochtone on n'est pas
en train de faire la bonne chose et donc
de remettre les personnes qui sont au
centre et qui ont l'expérience vécue et
qui sont les leaders et la communauté
totale elle-même
c'est la seule façon d'avancer pour de
vrai
d'une trentaine de communautés
autochtones qui n'ont pas un accès à
l'eau potable comment est-ce qu'on
explique ça dans un des pays les plus
riches de la planète c'était la question
qu'on s'était posée en 2015 comment
est-ce qu'on peut réellement avoir un
pays où les les communautés qui ont vécu
sur scène dans ce pays depuis des
millénaires ont pas accès à l'eau
potable c'est inacceptable c'est pour ça
qu'on s'était engagé en finir quand on
est arrivé au pouvoir il y en avait 109
à des habits d'ébullition long terme on
a maintenant levé à peu près 135 il
reste encore presque 30 communautés
effectivement à travers le pays mais
dans chaque communauté il y a un plan il
y a un projet il y a le financement et
on va y aboutir rapidement tout le monde
a le droit d'avoir de l'eau fraîche et
on va s'assurer de la voir
quelle sera la priorité de votre
gouvernement dans la prochaine année
quant à votre relation avec les POP
autochtones de s’assurer qu'à chaque
étape on bâtit sur le momentum qu'on a
qu'on a commencé c'est sûr que
dans les premières années il y a eu
beaucoup de travail de fonds pour créer
les capacités pour pour rebâtir un peu
des liens de confiance qui ont été
rompus pendant des années des décennies
mais maintenant on continue d'accélérer
que ce soit des investissements en
logements que ce soit des
investissements système de santé que ce
soit à des signatures d'entente sur
l'auto gouvernance on est en train
d'accélérer le pas et ça va être de
continuer à bâtir sur ce momentum qui
est pas seulement chez les Autochtones
mais chez les
Gabriel